Peter. I noticed you have something in your hand.
There it is the lawnmower 3.0 from manscaped.
And I don't know if you know this about me. I'm not really a beard wearing guy.
I've obviously had this for the duration since we've been doing the podcast
since, you know,
I guess it was June when we pretty much got a start on this season. Um,
but I've only been growing this beard because of the pandemic.
I thought it was a great idea.
Maybe I'd get a chance to grow a beard for the first time in my life,
many COVID beards and many people don't know me as a beard where,
and I don't really know.
Self has been, I've known you for many years and you were never a beard where,
and I was going to say something. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, nobody really. I mean, I don't mind it. Nobody really likes it.
I'm sure. And I've been,
I've been smart enough to keep it trim because I got this lawnmower 3.0 so all
year I've been keeping it trim,
but right now it looks a little bit fuzzy and time to go. Yeah.
So I was going to do this here and give you a show. I know, you know,
because you have.
I have one and honestly is the best. I mean,
I've had products like that before it is the best shaving product I've ever had.
It's not even close.
So I was going to just trim myself up and maybe not show you,
but show everybody else how, uh, how good I'm going to look afterwards.
So just to be clear, we will fast forward this. Well, we not,
nobody wants to see this. Okay, great.
This is kind of gross.
Yeah. Okay. All right.
So I know this is disgusting.
Yeah. In retrospect, uh, maybe take two, you throw down some paper towel,
perhaps.
I don't know if there's a take two now, but what do you think? No.
There's no question about the shaping quality and you were anywhere thrown it
around. They're pretty loosey goosey.
Not really seemingly worried about cutting.
And yourself. No.
And you don't need to because it's got the patented blade where it's no, no.
Nicks is what they say about this here. Blade.
I'll tell you what manscaped it provides the best in men's grooming and hygiene
made only from the best products and ingredients for the modern man manscaped
has changed the groom in game with their perfect package. 3.0 essentials kit.
Now this is a package that comes with the new and improved lot more 3.0 that the
water resistant cordless body tremor, which, uh,
there advanced skin safe technology and cutting edge ceramic blade makes your
trimming Nick free. So,
and the kit includes an anti chafing deodorant as opposed to a chafing.
Nobody wants the
chafing odor and nobody wants it.
It includes the anti chafing deodorant and a moisturizer to help you feel and
smell your best subscribers to what we call the perfect package. 3.0 kit,
get new replacement blades delivered to the door every three months.
And for a limited time, you get not one but two free gifts. So you get the shed,
which is a travel bag where she can put all your accoutrements in and you get
the patented high performance. Andy chafing manscaped boxer briefs. Yes.
I'm wearing mine right now. You probably are. And you'll have to take my word.
I'm gonna, I'm just gonna have to think you went for it.
You can get 20% off plus free
shipping@manscape.com when you use the promo code. What if that's right?
All one word. You still got something over here.
I will fix this in the break. Let's get to the show. Okay.
The sun formed first and then Jupiter formed out of the leftovers from the sun
and then everything else from that of the leftovers from Jupiter.
So in a really important sense,
if I want to understand where did the earth come from?
I bet to start with where did Jupiter come from?
Wow. You really do clean up. Well.
Right? I feel so much better, so much lighter. And, uh, you know,
th this is just feels right.
Not to be a hater on the beard, but this is the Pete. I know.
Thank you. I hope everybody else loves it too.
How do you feel about a little game of solar system trivia to this solar system
trivia? Well, why don't we bring the nation?
I mean,
if there's one thing I probably know a bit about is the solar a bit about as the
solar system working at, what if, you know, half of our videos are set in space,
so I could probably keep up.
You think, you know, your way around the solar system, do you.
Yeah, enough. I can, I can get there.
Okay. Let's get cosmic. Start the insanity.
Where is earth in relation or proximity to the
sun in the sort of order of planets where.
Well, this is solar system one Oh one. And, uh, actually, sorry,
it wouldn't really be solar system.
One-on-one I say that only because during the two thousands,
it kept getting rammed in my head. This NBC promo Thursdays.
Watch CTV third rock from the sun. Uh, John Lithgow,
Jane curtain, Kristin Johnson, of course the young JGL.
Who I think is a great actor and.
Joseph Gordon Levitt for the, for the non-conference.
I was just saying earlier, I really liked that guy.
I think he would be friends with us for some reason.
I would hope that he's a fan of the show. So yes, JGL.
If you are listening GL call us JG. Yes. We'd love to have you on, okay.
Question number two.
What is the smallest planet today in our solar
system.
Today? Well, I know where you're trying to lead me down in that pathway,
but here's a little tidbit that you don't, maybe you do now.
Maybe don't know a series.
A lot of people don't know series it's a dwarf planet,
which would technically make it the smallest planet in the solar system.
Although it's not technically a planet,
it's the largest body in the main asteroid field in between Mars.
And Jupiter yet to be upgraded to planetary status.
So in that case, I would say Pluto,
except for the fact that this is where you were trying to suck me up.
Pluto was downgraded in 2006 odd day for, uh,
for Pluto last planet status.
Although there's still a lot of people around the world who are fighting for
Pluto. Yes. Still, uh, the smallest planet then becomes mercury.
Mercury is going as points.
I'm going to tell you mercury just slightly larger than our moon. Hmm.
Well, for showing off, you'll be deducted points.
How does that next time just chest, uh,
finally, what is the largest planet in our solar?
I think, uh, every school boy knows that's stupid.
And that is correct. And of course,
most people do know that Jupiter is the biggest planet in the uni,
in the solar system, but not much more than that.
So what if Jupiter never existed?
Well, I can tell you, I do know a lot about that. Normally.
I wouldn't know a lot about something like that,
but I did provide the voice for the, what if video?
What if Jupiter never existed? I can, uh, tell you a few things about it,
but it'd probably be smarter for us to have a special guest that might be able
to expound upon that.
Like maybe an astronomer from NASA.
Why not?
Dr. Steve Levin received his PhD in physics from Berkeley in
1987.
He began his career at NASA jet propulsion laboratory in 1990.
He's the project scientist for NASA's Juno mission.
Juneau is a solar powered space craft,
which has been orbiting Jupiter since July 4th,
2016 for a few hours, every 53 days,
Juno passes within a few thousand kilometers of the giant planet and collects a
wealth of new information about Jupiter.
The data collected so far has revolutionized our understanding of Jupiter and of
giant planets in general.
Great to have you with us, Dr. 11, thanks for joining us here today.
On what if discussed.
My pleasure? It sounds like it's going to be fun.
Well, we're going to be talking Jupiter and it's fun.
We'll get to the bigger wood if and a bit, but to be honest,
Peter and I were talking sort of, uh, before you came on that. Yeah.
Most people know that, you know,
Jupiter's the biggest planet in the solar system. Times the size of earth,
11 times the size of earth. I think most people don't know that,
but a good factoid. Um, some people might know that it's a gas giant.
I didn't,
I didn't know for years that it was the fifth planet from the sun and that we're
separated, you know, Mars and then Jupiter that close to earth. But I mean,
basically my point is relatively little common knowledge about Jupiter.
It didn't feel like we'd been able to do much exploration while the Juno mission
that obviously you're such a big part of has changed the game.
How much have we learned about Jupiter since Juno,
uh, sorta left earth in 2016?
So, um,
the phrase we like to use around the project is it's a whole new Jupiter. Um,
basically we sent Juno Jupiter to measure a bunch of things that hadn't been
measured before to try to peak beneath the clouds, right?
Because even though Jupiter, as you said, 11 times bigger than the earth,
that's the radius. So you'd need, you could fit over a thousand or so inside.
It it's the most massive planet in the solar system by far
more than twice the mass of all the others combined.
And we've been studying it for hundreds of years.
Galileo looked at it with this telescope hundreds of years ago. Um,
even though we have all of that,
mostly we didn't know what lay beneath the clouds.
We'd look at Jupiter from the earth and its giant atmosphere and it's covered
with clouds.
So we sent Juno there to use gravity to
measure what the interior looks like to measure the magnetic field,
which comes from deep inside the planet to use Ray ATO waves.
They can see through the clouds, uh,
to go over the poles of Jupiter for the first time, really intake,
great big choose in the North and South where you can't see it from earth
because it's all in the same plane in the solar system,
a whole bunch of new kinds of measurements,
measuring particles in Jupiter's magnetic field, things like that.
And essentially everything we measured gave us a surprise
we were looking for. Is there a dense core down in the center?
And sure we expected something between maybe three and 20 times the mass of the
earth down in the center.
But what we found looks like maybe it's not a dense core with a sharp boundary.
Maybe it's sort of fuzzy. And it takes up like half the radius of the planet.
We measured the magnetic field and it was way more complex than we expected it
to be with all these bumps and wiggles in it. And,
and it doesn't look like a dipole like your S field and it's way different in
the North than the South.
We measured through the clouds with our radio receivers and we found that the
deep atmosphere doesn't get well-mixed the way you'd expect everybody thought,
you know, get beneath the clouds and it's this giant pile of gas.
It should be pretty much the same anywhere you look well, that's totally wrong.
So we got surprises. Every no thing. We took a look at,
even the pictures over the North and South poles,
it looks so different than what, the first time we looked at the pictures.
A lot of the people in the room were saying, are you sure of that stupid?
Or it just didn't look at all. Like Jupiter looks like from the side and then.
Those pictures have been shared, right. And people can,
where can people find those pictures.
Before I forget? Yeah. So there's this great opportunity out there.
So we have a website called mission Juneau, mission,
juneau.swri.edu,
but you can get to it from NASA's website or just Google mission Juneau and
the Juno cam images. That's the images from our visible light camera.
Basically we just dump the raw data out on the web and let anybody who wants
to play with it, make their own pictures, fix up the colors,
stitch things together, however much work you want to do and post them.
And we've gotten an amazing response. Uh,
we've there's several people out there who are real power users who would take
that data and turn it into these amazing pictures. Beginning to end.
There's a lot more people who take the intermediate steps and use those and try
stretching the color, changing the contrast,
or combining them to make movies and do some great things.
People are doing science. People are doing art.
People are making pretty pictures. It's really been fun. Yeah.
I talk about that planet in relation to our planet.
I don't know if everybody knows how much Jupiter may have affected Earth's
development, uh,
among other things it's protected us from a lot of flying rocks, but, uh,
what else?
Right. So the, the flying rocks thing is basically, uh,
if you imagine something drifting into the inner solar system,
when it gets near Jupiter's orbit,
Jupiter gravitationally is likely to perturb it and a lot more of those get shot
outward, then get shot inward so it can protect us. Um,
but more generally just the formation of the whole solar system.
When we look at how did planets form, which by the way,
is something scientists don't really understand all the details about the most
important models for how does the source system form, how do we get the planets?
Um, indicate that Jupiter came first, uh, not too surprising,
cause it's the largest it got there. First,
it got all the material and then it affected the formation of the whole rest of
the solar system. So there's, there's lots of ways to think about that.
But the one I liked the best is if you just look at our solar
system, like you were an alien or something,
and don't know what's there you'd come along, you'd see the sun. And you'd say,
maybe that's it. That's all there is,
is this star and you'd be 99 and a half percent, right.
Or something because almost all the masses in the sun.
And then if you looked a little bit further and said, Oh wait,
I see that spec that's Jupiter, right? You'd be more than two thirds.
Right? If you said,
that's all that's left because Jupiter's more than two thirds of the remaining
mass. Well,
the sun formed first and then Jupiter formed out of the leftovers from the sun
and then everything else from that of the leftovers from Jupiter.
So in a really important sense,
if I want to understand where did the earth come from?
I better start with where did Jupiter come from?
Otherwise I'm never going to get the picture.
So the,
I guess the short answer to what if Jupiter never existed would be
earth wouldn't have existed.
And I'm guessing the rest of the solar system wouldn't have existed.
Well,
I love that question because it's actually way more complicated than it sounds.
So imagine when you asked me that question,
the first thing I thought of is, okay.
Imagine Jupiter just didn't start to look for what would happen. Well,
the answer there is probably one of the other planets would have gotten a whole
lot bigger and sort of like Jupiter,
because if you look at the other really big ones at Saturn and Uranus and
Neptune,
what we think most likely happened is as the planets
formed, they drifted around.
Cause they're eating up the material and that makes the initial cloud of gas and
dust, and that changes their momentum.
And so their orbits shipped around and those other planets probably came
along after Jupiter was really big, Jupiter altered their orbits dramatically.
It looks like it probably sent them outward away from the sun and
they didn't have as much stuff.
Jupiter ate all the stuff first before they could get there.
So if Jupiter wasn't there,
well maybe Saturn drips in further and Saturday to all the stuff and looks a
whole lot like Jupiter does now of course, exactly where they ended up,
depends on all of that process. So if you take Jupiter out of the mix,
you totally rearranged things. Maybe we get a giant planet close to the sun,
or maybe we don't get a giant planet planet anywhere near the sun.
And there's really big ones out far away.
And we only have little planets close to the center or six of them or 10 of them
instead of eight or nine. Um,
all of that would be different if Jupiter didn't form.
And on top of that rattle, if you say, okay, suppose Jupiter forum,
do we got all the planets in the right place,
but now I'm going to just reach in and pop Jupiter out of the picture and say,
what happens? Then you get a totally different kind of answer, right?
The other planets don't get perturbed that much anymore,
but anything that's falling into the inner solar system,
light comments and asteroids, uh, mostly, really small rocks.
Maybe you wouldn't call them asteroids, meteors, things like that.
Without Jupiter there, they don't get returned their same way.
Their orbits are very different Mars. Isn't big enough to do much of anything.
So then you worry about, well, we get hit by comments more often,
or if you clucked Jupiter out of the picture after everything formed,
but before everything had settled down, then you'd get a different answer.
Maybe the amount of water on the earth might be different because Jupiter
probably influenced that. So any step along in the process,
if you don't have Jupiter, you get a different picture,
but what picture you get depends on when you took Jupiter away.
It's funny because these days, you know,
more people are talking about how interconnected things are here,
how we have to be reminded that even though there's seemingly a lot of distance
between Austin and the other side of the world, and in fact,
everything has this sort of butterfly effect,
if you will and affects everything else. So it's, it's,
it's interesting to see that that's the case.
Obviously the further we zoom out into the solar system as well,
you mentioned a smaller rocks, uh, and uh,
these days, of course, the moons around Jupiter, I think,
especially in this sort of astronomical circles, uh,
are getting as much attention, maybe even as Jupiter, uh,
especially Europa Ganymede, et cetera.
What Juno been able to sort of glean more about Jupiter's
moons?
Okay.
So first I should say our most important jobs so far about
Europa has been to stay the heck away.
From it. And that's.
Because people are very excited about the fact that Europa appears
to have a liquid water ocean underneath its icy Sur
and maybe find life in that ocean. So picture 20, 30, 40,
50 years from now,
you finally built a system that can do it and you fly to Europa and you land
on the ice and you dig down beneath the ice.
And we don't know whether that's a few feet or a few hundred miles,
but you dig through the ice, we get into the water, you sample the water,
you find life. And then you have to say,
but I don't know if that came from Europa or contamination for when Juno hit it
50 years ago,
that would be a problem because we're there to study Jupiter.
We have to be better.
And we didn't go through all the steps you do for say a Mars mission to make it
as clean as possible and have no bacteria on it or anything like that.
Nothing that could survive.
We have to show we're not going to contaminate Europa.
And what we did at the beginning is we said, all right, well, we're,
they're going to study the, the main planet, not Europa.
We'll just stay the heck away from however we're coming near the end of our
prime mission. We're writing actually sending it in today.
I think an extended mission proposal to NASA to ask,
to keep giving us money to continue because the spacecraft's doing well.
And we have lots of great new science we can do.
And part of that proposal,
which of course NASA will have to decide if they have the money.
Part of that proposal is to study Europa because we think
with our radio receivers, um, that we use to look at the atmosphere,
we can look at Europa and tell you something about maybe how thick the ice is
and whether there's water near the surface. Um,
we have other instruments that if we're lucky,
maybe we'll see a plume and be able to tell something about whether Europa has
geysers are not sticking out in this space.
We can look at all the other satellites.
And I would not give that as a SUNY.
It gets funded as a, um,
like prime mission that studies the satellites because that's not what we were
there for,
and we're not geared to do everything you want to do to study Europa,
but it's a great advanced scout mission for NASA's mission,
Europa clipper,
or European mission Jews that want to go to Jupiter and study those moons and
learn a lot more.
We can learn a little bit that might help them refine where they do their
measurements and what they do.
We can measure some things that they weren't designed to measure because they're
focused on, on stuff that is more Europa specific.
And we have instruments that were really focused on Jupiter.
So we measure slightly things.
There's lots of great stuff we can do if we get,
if NASA decides that they want to fund our extended mission or has the money to
fund the extended missions.
And if it includes your own breaking news here on what F.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, to say that this is the golden age of space,
exploration would be an understatement. We're talking about the Juno mission.
NASA launched a probe to Mars earlier this year.
We got the announcement last week and we had a guest on talking about the
possibility of phosphene on Venus and what that might spur in terms of further
exploration. What is it like to be working at NASA these days?
I got to say it's really fun. I mean,
I I've been working for NASA one way or the other for about 30 years.
And, um,
it's always been fun because we're exploring where trying to figure out
things where nobody knows the answer. Um,
but right now we're getting close to some really important answers. Uh,
we're learning, you know, it's, it's in my lifetime,
in my career as a scientist is, you know, at the beginning of my career,
nobody had discovered any planets around any other star besides our own.
Now it's practically practically root Chino.
They found another planet around some other star.
And it's only interesting if it's a special case,
if it's more Earth-like or it's really close to its star,
or really far from its star or things like that,
we're getting distributions of bath.
We're learning how many planets there are typical plea,
and there's our own solar system.
We're learning about different ways to look for life within our own solar
system. And we're getting further along doing it.
Our robots have gotten so good that we can launch robotic spacecraft and do
these exploration things that, you know, when I was growing up, I thought only,
you know, you'd have to have people there to do. And of course,
it's way easier to send a robot than it is to send a person mostly because the
robot doesn't care if you bring, give it a ride home.
So all of that,
it's really a great time to be doing space exploration.
Yeah. And I mean, with the way the world is these days,
I know Peter and I have experienced this before that when we get to talk to
people like yourself that, you know,
help us zoom out and remind us that the world isn't our little navel
gazing day to day, that there's just obviously so much beyond this planet.
So much to look forward to,
and even so much to be optimistic about the future versus all the dystopian
sci-fi and post-apocalyptic stuff. I think we see a lot.
It's easy to forget that. So this is great. Can you stick around and talk?
You mentioned some of those exoplanets and kind of future NASA missions.
Can you stick around for a bit? Sure.
So we w we are going to take a break with Dr. Levin right now,
and he will be part of the extended audio podcast, which you can find,
I guess if you're watching YouTube goods, the link is where people.
Listen, if you're watching this on YouTube right now,
you want to click on the link and you'll get the extended audio version of the
podcast, and we can hear the rest of the conversation with Dr. Levin. Um,
but if that's all the time you have for us today, then, uh, well,
that's fine too. You can,
you're going to stick around because we're still gonna do a little video chat
after this. Um, and then we'll check in.
Part two later. Yeah. So Peter now sort of sum up our,
our takeaways from the first half, where can people,
you mentioned the website for the, for the footage, uh, from the Juno mission,
where can people find that again and where can people follow your work?
So, um,
the easiest thing for people to remember is if you go to NASA's website and
search for Juneau, you'll find out all this stuff with links to everything.
But the main Juneau website is a site called mission Juneau. So it's mission
juneau.swri.edu. And if you just Google mission Juneau, you'll find it.
Or if you do a web search for Juno cam, you'll find us, um,
it's pretty easy,
just so long as you got NASA or Jupiter or something in there to keep from
getting confused with all the other Junos out there.
I like the Juno awards up here. Google will get you there, basically,
which honor the best of Canadian music you don't want.
That's an entirely different Juno. Yes.
Dr. Levin will do on that site too. It's pretty interesting.
I think Alanis Morissette one in Juneau back in the day as, as Alanise,
but that's a story for another whatever. Okay. Dr. Levin sit tight.
We'll be back with you in a sec. And, uh, Peter and oddly,
back to sort of sum up our takeaways from our conversation with Dr. Levin about
the Juno mission and what if Jupiter never existed?
Cool.
So I guess like Dr. Lebanon and the people at the jet propulsion laboratory
with NASA, uh, they learn stuff. We learn stuff.
They learned that some of the things that they had assumed or known about
Jupiter turned out not to be true or, or,
or were at least more than they had expected. Of course,
because they got to finally actually look at it from the quality pictures,
quality picture.
There's deeper.
So they got to go beneath the gas surface and see what's happening down there.
Had some assumptions about it. But in fact, we're, I think happily proven wrong.
I like when a NASA does some things like that and we find
out about it and we can bring it to the viewers. It's almost that fast. I mean.
Well, I mean, in this particular case,
you're having some real time learning going on, because again,
he's giving us the sort of the backstory as to what they learned at the time.
And then we're learning that into,
to your point then people listening or watching or learning. I mean,
I learned also that we have this sort of big brother,
big sister relationship with Jupiter on earth, right? I mean,
it's been essentially shielding us protecting us for all this time.
And I had never, honestly, before I know it sounds stupid maybe,
but I'd never thought that, you know,
all that sprays debris and asteroids coming in this direction would have
naturally potentially hit us if we weren't kind of protected from that.
Well, we know, what I thought was interesting was that if Jupiter, he gave us a,
an idea of how the universe was formed. Jupiter obviously was, or not.
Obviously we learned today or I learned today,
it was the second object in the solar system.
And if it hadn't been there or if it wasn't there,
if there's a possibility earth wouldn't be here. Right?
Yeah. So it's not a small relationship we have with Jupiter.
And what if Jupiter never existed as it turns out again,
as we sort of put it out there, if Jupiter never existed,
there's the possibility that earth never existed.
But he also added a bit of a, sort of a caveat to that,
that whoever else would have been there,
they might've gotten that say the leftover mass.
So maybe in a different scenario, earth would have been the size of Jupiter.
And instead of having 7 billion people here we'd have 700 billion people here.
Or maybe it wouldn't have, uh,
stayed in the habitable zone or maybe it would have gotten too big and that
wouldn't have been enough water on it to sustain life.
There would have been a whole host of other reasons why maybe life didn't exist,
never came to be on.
Earth. You know what it sounds like to me, Peter, it.
Sounds like a story for another. What if, well, uh,
if you want to hear more of our conversation with, uh, NASA, Steve Levin,
and you're watching the video podcast on YouTube, well,
what you're going to do is click on the link below and it will take you to the
extended audio version. Now,
some of you are listening already on the audio podcast.
There's no link for you. Don't look for anything, stay tuned now.
So join us on the other side, we'll talk more about life on other planets and,
uh, and, uh, space exploration, a bunch of ration Europa.
Um, and if that's all the time you have for us today, well, thanks for watching.
You can join us next week.
When we talk about the mysteries of the octopus with the director of the film,
my octopus teacher, you won't see an octopus in the same light ever again.
No, I mean, they're fascinating. That's why that movie has blown up on Netflix,
my octopus teacher. And it'll be really cool to get some insight.
What if has done a couple of octopus or PI videos and pusses, uh,
but, uh, this is going to be a really cool conversation.
Right? That's next week on what if discussed.